[Musique]
molène est une commune bretonne non
continental de brest à molène il y a
deux heures et demi de voyage deux
heures et demi de mer de grosse mer
parfois car molène est une île le bateau
qui vous y amène prend au sortir de la
rade de brest à direction nord-ouest par
temps clair une fois doubler la pointe
saint-mathieu l'île de molène émergent à
l'horizon cachant la grande île
d'ouessant qui est plus loin encore à
trois quarts d'heure de mer
[Musique]
village triangulaire s'est accrochée sur
la face sud est de l'île bien à l'abri
des vents froids qui souffle du nord
[Musique]
l'île molène ressemble à un grand
chapeau chinois qui auraient une
superficie de moins de 1 km carrés au
sud sont groupés des terrains cultivés
non cadastrée à peine des enclos des
parcelles de terre plutôt n'excédant pas
souvent 20 mètres carrés à cause des
continuelles partage familiaux
[Musique]
la place centrale le coeur du village
c'est son port de ce port partira ce
matin vers le continent
la maigre pêche de ces jours derniers
les araignées de mer quelques homards et
langoustes aussi grain et beaucoup de
tourteaux voilà c'est aux 400 coups puis
pour la bande des six oui tu es chez
nous quoi combler chamoux quand ça sent
le prix psyché ou lcd servant des eaux
particulièrement bien où j'en ai vendu
le double clic tout ça aurait sur le
marché à vous et on peut compter x trop
bon il y 2 o mais je reviens si ce
contrôle
j'approche entre trop de même voyez
quand le vent par ailleurs le par
ailleurs il en reçoit wall st louis ou a
pas de récompense pour tous ou presque
j'ai trouvé ça parce que marchand de
marchands dans le point coursan
bénéfices comme leurs yeux c'est pareil
ça soit le double de celle là et je suis
là juste un grand pied bien plein parce
que d'ailleurs de l'isi
vous connaissez mieux que moi si le code
n'est pas bronzer seins ne voulons pas
d'argent général le cra qui vient de
changer sa coque
il est malade il a troqué clair oui mais
vous paie pour s'en rendre compte il
suffit la couleur il suffit d'appuyer
brédois son appel à la levée moment-là
vous semblez j'ai besoin de nous avant
de nous
[Musique]
le seul camion de molène traverse de
temps à autre les rues étroites du
village ces rues semblent refuser d'être
droite pour pouvoir courir plus
longtemps dans l'île
il arriva ce camion du moins on le
raconte de rouler à près de 40 km à
l'heure
mais c'est uniquement sur le port et sur
une distance de 20 mètres à peine
il y a aussi trois ou quatre voitures à
juste titre appelé particulière est
presque en état complet de marche des
voitures d'ailleurs pourquoi faire et
pour aller où
il faut à peine 5 à 10 minutes pour se
rendre d'un bout à l'autre de l'île et à
dire vrai à molène personne n'est pressé
[Musique]
en outre nombreux sont ceux qui trouvent
plus agréable de traverser le bourg au
gré du vent
[Musique]
une crêperie oui nous sommes en bretagne
au hasard des rues encore quelques
autres commerces
[Musique]
un bistrot sur le port où les pêcheurs
aiment à se retrouver à toute heure du
jour
[Musique]
non ce n'est pas l'infirmière l'autorité
médicale permanente du village qui
trouble le calme de la rue avis de la
mairie demain les docteurs le manach au
dispensaire à partir de 11h pour
vaccination ainsi que l'auditeur
nauviale médecin il n'y a pas de médecin
et ben non pas souvent faim oui j'ai à
peine comme ya 15 jours déjà il ya plus
de médecins et même un mois depuis le
docteur joly de brest voilà ici c'est
plutôt rare ne vous pouvez pas aller
voir un médecin a lieu à 20 il faudrait
l'hélicoptère mais ça coûterait cher au
département mais il vient quand même
chercher et l'ordre dans la journée si
un martien malade si c'est la nuit le
chacal canaux sauvetage qui va il n'y a
personne qui s'occupe du moulin de là
pour voler sans fin c'est assez
compliqué si caillet magasin la preuve
voilà si on est il faut pas une balade
dans l'île parce que c'est rare
notamment un médecin pneumologue cette
île c'est une île voilà et vous et bien
moi je suis ici depuis 10 ans comme un
de molène natif de molène tout je veux
pas m'en donnais mon pays que j'aime
bien et je fais le cache en fait qu'il
n'a pas appris sand ils n'en font pas
autre chose
il n'y a pas de norme vous violez contre
huawei continue à votre tour
le moyen de transport le plus utilisé à
molène et le plus pratique aussi est
encore la brouette pour les brouettes
aucune réglementation particulière ni de
stationnement ni de circulation voilà
qui facilite singulièrement le travail
du sympathique gardes-champêtres
le vent froid du nord souffle sur molène
c'est l'heure de notre rendez vous avec
le maire
cependant monsieur pour aller à la
mairie à la mairie par ici si vous
voulez venir à 100 que moi là bon mais
ni quelle le long de la rue qu'il faut
prendre
outre la rue nous autres on n'a pas de
nom de la rue delerue de l'hôtel ici oui
oui le bruit n'ont pas de nom non non
non aucune c'est tous des chemins quand
on dirait quoi oui mais en a beaucoup au
oui oui oui au final tellement 1 et vous
arrivez à vous retrouver
oh oui parce que lille n'est pas grande
nous plaît monsieur le maire combien y
at-il de mollet n'est dans votre commune
il ya environ 596 d'après le dernier
recensement il y avait 6 ans 4e
recensement précédent
vous voyez toute petite diminution et
quelle est leur activité actuelle il ya
leurs activités la principale activité
évidemment c'est la pêche
oui moi ça a été jusqu'à présent
maintenant il ya tout de même un peu
moins d'activités du côté de la pêche
et quelle sorte de pêche la pêche aux
crustacés bien sûr la langouste le
homard le crabe araignée physiquement ou
bruit le pen joue des mots tout à fait
il ya aussi bien sûr le rappelle le
poisson vers la palangre le combat fin
très peu c'est surtout le crustacé qui
est la principale pêche voilà
sur le lieu de travail des pêcheurs la
relève des casiers et commencer
[Applaudissements]
alors quoi de la rouste
lors d'une de leurs saisons mais chez
ces demandes ont toujours été combien
c'est pato courant voire de langoustes
et mambo s'isolant vous seul on l'a eue
de lingostière il avait une qui
n'étaient pas dans le casier elle était
dessus elle faisait le produit doit
faire 4 kg et n'allait pas dans le
boulot était le travail ils avaient une
seule la demande à sa femme est comme un
casier en 136 une seule dans son morceau
non dans sa journée d'hier ça
aujourd'hui les enlever quand même foyer
relève qu'une fois par jour 250 kwc
passera qu'est-ce qu'ils ont béni
quinzaine de la gauche à l'arsenal ans
pour tous
mais de telles journées de pêche
décevante avec des relèves de casiers
vide
ont-elles toujours été le lot des
pêcheurs auront une période d'ailleurs
hervé guerrera 49 50 il y avait à
l'époque il y avait comme importe
combien d'anciens moulins y avait 30
euros avec les deux d'une horloge et les
gardiens n'en a dit à 123,60 ensemble et
c'est une moyenne et son vampire les
volets gars de dialogue écoute quasi que
nous c'était une moyenne de une tonne à
une tonne à la moto même heure à nous au
mollet n'étaient arrivés titre à brive
il va envoyer dans mes aînés là et c'est
justement ce qui avait donné le coup de
folie ou essence et que dès que les
marins de camaret audierne ans il a été
chef du tour de moulin
oui évidement ils sont tous venus sous
ils ont remis tous les ragots qu'ils
avaient dans le port de ronnie and to
you et il y avait de mieux contrôler et
retapé sans être un délai de tous et
tous les sens il aurait tant et plus de
bien non il ya eu un fléchissement tout
de suite dans les années 50 de 53 2 33
ça tombait
ils ont déclassé oui il y avait trop de
transformation pour le fait qu tués
le travail de modernisme profond travail
et souverain c'est à dire deux cas des
banques et par la suite on s'est grillé
en finir c'est à dire que sur la même
ligne et vous alliez 25-30 casier ça
dépend coin est alors évidemment les
moyens est accru de boulevard che
on ne nous sont passés de 40 câline sont
passés à 70 80 et alors que 105 ans mais
il reste combien de bateaux il est bien
vite et
malheureusement dans deux trois mois
avec le manque d'équipage le mouvement
qui se prépare avec le départ des jeunes
dans
la royale nous pensons qu'il reste cinq
bateaux c'est bien peu la pêche se meurt
que peuvent alors faire ce qu'ils
abandonnent la pêche comme de nîmes à
100 par exemple nous lui avons demandé
ils avaient désarmé qu'est ce que vous
faites et bien maintenant ma foi lots
restent plus est ce ce que l'on vit
changé depuis déjà quelques années vous
voyant la pêche décliner d'une année à
l'autre tu es bien je me suis décidée
avec la famille et les enfants les
enfants à se lancer dans la branche
tourisme qui à molène je pense lula le
calme
les possibilités de pêche dans l'île et
bien en faire le touriste trouvera son
c'est certain à travers ces deux hôtels
restaurants molène offre aux touristes
en plus de la pêche et du calme de l'air
pur et iodée des contacts amicaux avec
une population accueillante et du
dépaysement tlc grimaud n'y ai passé
toute l'année un peu chez le web ont
aussi moins de six mois six mois et demi
cette année ont au moins six mois et
demi qui est en plus les premiers temps
[Musique]
on a fait six mois vous êtes de molène
non non on est de viol il aurait et
pourquoi les gens de molène ne pèche
palais beaumont
c'est leur métier de pêcheur
le grand-père des pêcheurs les jeunes
préfèrent est pêcheur que faire ce
métier parce que tout c'est un peu dur
et ccp train de changer de profession
pourtant je crois que le gréement est
plus rentable que la pêche avait retiré
la galerie
[Musique]
les crustacés ont diminué les prix les
halles que ça ça au moins tous les ans
la récolte du goémon des laminaires dont
a besoin de plus en plus l'industrie est
sans doute la richesse future de molène
est ce que vous prévoyez une activité
nouvelle pour l'avenir
oui il y aurait peut-être l'industrie
des arts que le oui non oui seulement si
évidemment le problème maintenant c'est
de le faire sécher avait pu voir sur la
petite île courrier en face là est un
endroit où l'on fait sécher le web on
n'est des bouées mouillées qui sont là
ce ne sont pas des gens de chez nous
sont des gens qui gagnent tous vers
l'eau et parce qu'ils seront toujours
fait ça sans doute aussi nous on ne l'a
pas fait mais je crois que s'il y avait
un moyen de faire sécher louis hémon
artificiellement les installations pour
cela et bien sans doute que certains se
lancerait dans cette activité là et ce
serait rentable et du web où ils n'en
manquent pas à tous et nous on tâche
queue de poisson certainement et les
installations seraient communal ah oui
faudrait que je sois candidat l'horrible
cela de mon habitude j'ai bien sûr et
votre budget et lass est toujours en
déséquilibre trop quoi cela bientôt pas
cela parce qu'il nous avons très peu de
recettes et des recettes pourront pas
retrouver ce n'est pas possible des
dépenses bien sûr retrouvez nous hélas
alors chaque année ça nous oblige
évidemment de demander une subvention d
équilibre au département mais les jeux
contes les meules aînés ne paient pas
d'impôts non on ne paie pas d'impôt si
on veut ce qu'on appelle un pôle
immobilier mais nous payons des impôts
sous toutes ses formes
il y a il y a par exemple si vous voulez
aller jusqu'à brest de prendre une paire
de chaussures vous faire arracher une
dent parce qu'ils n'auront pas de
dentiste ici non plus et bien tout cela
revient très cher parce qu'il faut
passer deux nuits par le service
régulier même en été lorsque le bateau
fait le service journalier ça ne mange
pas du tout on arrive à braise à 20
heures il faut reprendre le bateau
lendemain matin à 8h30 on a donc pu rien
faire encore passer la journée ce qui
fait passer de renvoyer un peu à quoi se
mêle alors tous les denrées qui arrivent
ici le pal dans la viande évidemment
tout ça est majoré du prix du transport
ce qui est tout à fait normal d'envoyer
nous payons quand même des impôts sous
une certaine forme payer des impôts
indirects pour les autorités beaucoup
aujourd'hui il y à une navette
il vient donner sens et se dirige vers
brest
[Musique]
dans un mois nous allons faire à leurs
tirs
poisson de presse de
pour le boson comment ça se fait qu'on
est obligé de prendre une petite vedette
pour aller au bateau très bien mais
c'est pas pour ça alors il faut que le
look des grands chefs solo qu est-ce que
les gens connaissent molène sur le
continent le ballon quand il ment aux
pressions moi je ne les prends
pour ceux qui viennent à molène qui
quittent l'île le transbordement et
parfois dangereux surtout pour les
personnes âgées
mais en général ces petits ennuis
n'empêche pas les mollets n'est d'être
satisfait de leur existence
éloignez retirer du continent et vous
vous êtes l'heureux et molène vous avez
été vous allez souvent cantine
[Applaudissements]
uniquement un mollet voilà des travaux
les molènes sais ce que c'est que la
mort ou s'il tient le garde champêtre
toujours sur la brèche fait office de
fossoyeur une chose qui est assez
remarquable essai c'est que le cimetière
est très très propre ah oui parce que
tout le monde parle et on de la même
couleur
qu'est ce que vous préférez vous et
chaque année à la toussaint alors tout
est refait par exemple qui sait à
l'étranger bien on n'est pas chez nous
mais mon anglais ou allemand ou en
italien ou ne pas vous et henry miller
pourquoi ça nous allons pouvoir d'un
côté elle est mort des autres ça c'est
curieux ça et il a fait beaucoup de
morts étranges et actuellement nous
sommes un des ponts pour y trouver le
savez le pouvoir
jour de tristesse pour malaise
on
comme le veut une coutume particulière
ici lorsqu'une femme est enterré ce sont
les femmes qui portent le corps
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
entouré par la mer dans un secteur
redouté des navigateurs molène a connu
des heures tragiques péris en mer trois
mots lourds de sens pour le peuple de
marins travaillant au milieu des rochers
qui prolonge quelque peu l'europe
le sémaphore de molène c'est le chien de
garde des marins en eau du lever au
coucher du soleil
un guetteur suit la navigation des
bateaux dans ses parages extrêmement
dangereux
[Musique]
monsieur le maire ont dit qu'ils voient
où ils s'envoient son sens est ce que
pour me gêne c'est pas un peu pareil
pas tout à fait mais il ya aussi un
proverbe en effet il vaut amoled ou à sa
peine et ou qu'on parlait très bien où
ils ont placé ne sont pas tellement doux
et sans non plus un homme soit le sens
où le thème il ya beaucoup de travail
ici c'est une vraie rocheuses attrait
rocheuses oui il ya très souvent des
naufrages évidemment ça vous appelez
très souvent à sortir on avait pu
d'ailleurs voir la maison du canot de
sauvetage le jean charcot
mais voilà il ya là un problème
justement on ne peut pas toujours lancé
le cas note à toutes heures de marée ces
ingrédients mais vraiment il faudrait
trouver une solution parce qu'on est
tous très souvent appelés à sortir de
lui on ne peut pas financer le calloch
par manque d'eau alors que si simplement
les avions une cale loyers dans le nord
de l'île
cal de lancement du canal on pourrait le
lancer à toutes heures de marée et donc
répondre à tous les appels et en même
temps cette qualification protégé par un
maul nécessairement servirait
d'accostage au bateau qui fait la
liaison entre le continent et molène
on ferait donc d'une pierre deux coups
oui mais sans doute trouve donc au
mollet n'a pas assez d'importance tant
de coin du sauvetage qu'aux points de
vues communes pour qu'on s'en soucie de
ces améliorations
pourtant au point de vue sauvetage
molène travail soins oui très souvent
très souvent les panneaux qui le disons
mais on l'a bien dit que voler l'été la
capitale mondiale du sauvetage c'est les
panneaux qui avons donné ce nom à lille
mais voilà il faut toujours être prêt
quoi
puisque quand il ya quelque chose le
sémaphore le bréslien donald à la can on
est aussitôt tout le monde est là après
ça me dit pas plus
donc si en bateau se trouve en
difficulté ah oui nous voilà partis
aussitôt vous partez pour les sauver
grâce aux courriers et vous sortez très
souvent cet hiver on l'a senti pas mal
hein ça s'est souvent arrêté pour
l'allemand la subissons déjà pour le
terreau les solutés également de rien et
pour l'autre dame de carl un chalutier
lorientais
et pour sorties sont toujours bénévole
avait exhorté par n'importe quel temps
par l'imposant avec les jours ici c'est
pas si grave et si c'est possible
il arrive tu vois la mer étant je ne
pourrais pas se dire mais si
impossibilité pour toutes ces convois
là-bas derrière vous qu'est ce que c'est
c'est un bateau c'est un chalutier qui
s'est venu s'échouer là à peu près de
voir ça vous êtes sorti pour débourrer
mais vous avez sauvé le seul à sauver
l'équipage nous a menés à vos lettres
les ornements à l'intérieur de l'église
parle aussi de la mer une plaque marque
une date dans l'histoire de molène la
tragédie qui triment castanet alors vous
vos parents du bourg à confesseur oui
mon pays étaient décorées
comment ça c'est un père et tous ils ont
eu la médaille de la reine victoria
ça c'était un naufrage
un naufrage mais ils sont perdus touché
il ya eu 12 de sauver sa langue avant
que l'essor de deux ans
heureusement que ça n'arrive pas très
souvent ça non c'est qu'un paquebot
il chargeait d'or dont il a été récupéré
non aux places les italiens ont été
plongés dessus dans à 5000 papa
mais vous avez été récompensés par les
anglais ici de finale oui oui on a eu
une grande citerne la gravité rockets
alors et dans le victoria ainsi terme
c'est important vous attend du sila au
près mais avant ça il y avait eu avec
des petites citerne du tout il ya un
siècle il n'y avait sur l'île qu'un
puits d'eau saumâtre l'eau douce de
molène c'est de l'eau de pluie qu'il
faut recueillir par tous les moyens
jusqu'à la dernière goutte au pied de
chaque habitation en prise directe avec
le 3 une cité
[Musique]
glos et chose rare
pas de machine à laver et il est hors de
question de faire la lessive a grandi
l'heure d'ouverture des robinets de la
citerne communal c'est l'heure d'une
corvée pour les mollets neige une corvée
qui ne les empêche pas d'ailleurs de
garder le sourire
autour de ce point de rendez vous des
femmes on y fait des rencontres
c'est pas vrai ajoute la mère de deux
chars course et moi ma mère de charteau
et il est très sympathique on a
interviewé l'audio alors c'est vous donc
voilà mkii qui avait fauché dans le jura
charte ou dans les bateaux de sauvetage
ravi 3904 vous avez donc la clinique
oui parce que l'enfant se transforme en
veillant technique
quand il est né il n'avait rien promis
de tours de rick le poteau de mon mari
bill ficelles d'un pantalon serré qu'on
a mis sur de la délivrance
vous avez à 9 ans j'avais 11 11
[Musique]
tout le monde n'a pas eu 11 enfants à 39
ans certes mais tout le monde a eu
l'honneur d'avoir un fils surnommé
charcot heureusement on ne s'y
retrouverait plus car dans ce village
les enfants ne manquent pas
[Musique]
pour la majorité des enfants
le mot parent est synonyme de mer
écrivez votre mari sa fille qui n'est
pas souvent la partie depuis la veille
de noël et sera l'ardennais conjoint c4
moins six mois que ça craint ce qu'un
joli sur les pieds qu'est ce qu'elle
pense de cela est-ce que leur place
n'est pas louis saha l'élégance 1
quand le père vient on est bien contente
quand il pas surtout pas les gosses qui
souffre
il ya beaucoup de femmes de marins de
commerce il est nommé au oui oui la plus
tard il l'a fait je ne donne pas à l' on
ne peut pas rester à la maison des
jeunes gens qui se réunissent le soir
dans leur foyer savent que leur avenir
est pratiquement tout tracé
la plupart de jeunes ici qu'est ce qu'on
brestois la pêche et le commerce le
commerce qu'est ce que ça veut quand
même à la marge antique de l'allemagne
dans charmed à mannheim et bien beaucoup
de jeunes beaucoup que la pêche ne donne
pas il faut bien trouver un débouché aux
peurs qu'est ce que vous avez comme
diversion en volant par exemple demain
dimanche le bal le bal avant 7h30 a
pressés toute la journée pendant deux
ans de sport désir je sois tout sauf de
bonheur madar alors florence demain
obama mais une fois n'est pas coutume ce
dimanche-là florence et aller au bal
[Musique]
je ne
[Applaudissements]
le courant est revenu et avec lui
d'autres rythmes plus modernes que nous
semble guère goûté les jeunes filles qui
ont déserté la piste
[Musique]
au bistrot il y à la télévision une
bonne raison de se retrouver devant le
récepteur entre hommes exclusivement et
de boire le dernier verre jusqu'à
l'heure du dîner
comment lutter les cartes sont en sursis
le boxeur a non non non non c'est
longueur cholet ses grands actionnaires
alors l'heure solaire nous nous
travaillons qu'avec leurs salaires on
n'est pas plus avancé d'avoir votre
heure nous puisque chan convient pas du
tout pour la marée c'est l'heure de la
france l'heure de la france n'est pas
l'homme ammar et je le charme de ces
piles ou les nuits ne sont éclairés que
par une seule langue sur le port le
charme particulier de mme allen doit
être dû à cette volonté des hommes de
continuer à vivre au rythme de la mer
qui les encerclent
[Musique]